Congressman Mike Gallagher joins
Congressman, or should I say.
Well, I guess it's early to say,
Chairman,
so I'll just call you
Congressman for now.
You're the incoming chair
of this new select committee on
You say
we're in the early stages
of a new Cold War with China.
Do you view China
as an enemy of the United States
And what is your biggest priorit
for this new committee?
On day one of the new Congress
I view the Chinese Communist Par
as an enemy of the United States
But it's important
that we don't conflate
the Chinese Communist Party
and the Chinese people.
I think that's
absolutely critical
to our long term competition wit
And I view the CCP
in some ways
as an enemy of its own people.
Look at the way in
which Xi Jinping has repressed
the nationwide protests
surrounding his failed COVID
zero policies.
Look at the way
in which they've used
some of the tools of techno
totalitarian surveillance
they're perfecting in Xinjiang p
in a modern day
concentration camp
and exported
that around the country
to control the rest of their cit
So it's important that we make t
that distinction constantly.
And the most important thing
we want to do,
as with this new select
committee,
is make this a bipartisan effort
Speaker elect
McCarthy wants the Democrats
to participate in this.
He wants us to be serious.
And to the extent possible,
we want to identify
where Congress can speak with on
when it comes to the policy
that best positions us to win th
term competition with the CCP.
So the US Senate just voted unan
to ban TikTok from government ph
TikTok is a popular app
that is from China.
You have a bill to ban
TikTok completely
nationally over its ties to Chin
And because of national security
for the 100 million TikTok users
in the US,
including two thirds of teenager
including two teenagers I know v
What information
could the Chinese government
be collecting about them,
and should they delete that app?
They should, and I recognize
particular as a younger
member of Congress,
this will make me very unpopular
with your teenagers and many oth
But the fundamental problem is t
Tik Tok
is owned by bytedance,
and bytedance is effectively con
by the Chinese Communist Party.
The editor
in chief of Bytedance, for examp
is a CCP secretary
and has talked
about making sure all product li
all business lines follow approp
political control.
So the question we have to ask
is whether we want
to give the CCP the ability
to track our location, track
what websites
we visit,
even when we're not using the Ti
app itself.
And increasingly,
since a large
percentage of young Americans
use Tik Tok to get their news,
whether we want them
to have the ability
to selectively edit
that news, it's
as if in 1958, given that TikTok
is on the cusp of becoming
the most powerful media company
in America,
we would have allowed the KGB in
to buy the New York Times,
The Chicago Tribune, The Washing
all combined
I think this is a bad idea,
and I'm proud to say
that my bill is now bipartisan.
I have a Democrat, Raj Krishnamo
who is joining me in introducing
We've heard Senator Mark Warner
voice concerns in the Senate.
So my hope is that
we make that bipartisan case
and now
every member of the Senate is on
saying that
TikTok is a national security co
And that it should be banned
from government phones.
So we're making the case
we have a long way to go legisla
So I had the top Republican comm
from the Federal Communications
Commission, Brendan Carr, on my
a few days
ago, and I asked him about TikTo
He told me that American kids
using TikTok are bombarded
with addictive content, pushing
self-harm, pushing eating disord
while the Chinese version of the
in China is pushing educational
and a mandatory time limit.
So Chinese kids
can't be on that app too long.
Do you think China is doing
that purposefully
trying to use technology
to harm American children?
The short answer is we don't kno
But Brendan Carr's called it
digital fentanyl
and I think that comparison is a
for two reasons.
One, as he points out,
it's highly addictive,
highly destructive.
It's increasing the loneliness,
and rising rates of suicide
and depression
we're seeing among America's you
And also like actual fentanyl
ultimately you can trace it back
to China.
The precursor chemicals
for fentanyl come from China, of
So I think it's a very good comp
by FCC Commissioner Brendan Carr
and that's one of the many reaso
why we need to take bipartisan a
to ban it.
And as I said before,
the ability to edit the news,
I just think
is a massive tool
and weapon that we don't want
to give the CCP.
The other thing is this
whether or not
they're doing it
intentionally, there's another a
in our relationship
Chinese propagandists, Chinese
wolf, warrior
diplomats, are all over
our social media companies
Twitter, Facebook,
spreading dangerous lies
about the United States attackin
Well, at the same time,
they deny their own citizens in
access to those very same
technology platforms.
That doesn't make sense.
That's not a reciprocal relation
So one thing I've encouraged
Twitter executives to do
is to apply a standard
that says if you deny
your citizens access,
we won't allow you access to our
to spread dangerous lies.
There's all sorts of ways
we can get
at the information competition,
the ideological competition
that's an essential part
of winning this new Cold War.
I have to ask you.
Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy still as of right
now, does not seem to have the 2
he needs to become speaker.
It looks as though this delay
is going to muck up committees
such as yours getting up and run
The Wall Street Journal editoria
usually pretty friendly.
And Republicans said, quote,
Too many House
Republicans are too dimwitted
to understand
the use of uses of power
and how to wield it.
They'd rather rage against the m
to no useful effect, unquote.
Is this internal fight
hurting your party's ability to
even before you take over
Well, I
think we will get
there, and I'm not budging off
my support of Speaker McCarthy.
But you're right to suggest
that there's no time to waste he
We can't spend
all of January
just with mired in this internal
We need to populate various comm
There's all sorts of work
that needs to be done
in terms of basic oversight
of the executive branch,
as well as articulating policies
and finding areas where we can p
productive bipartisan legislatio
So my hope is that we get passed
Kevin McCarthy has done
a great job over the last month
of reaching out to his detractor
and saying, okay, what rules cha
do you want to see?
How do we fix this institution?
It's not going to be perfect.
Obviously, we only have control
of one chamber of government,
but there's a lot of things we c
So it might take multiple vote s
but I believe we are going to ge
And the fact
that Speaker
McCarthy wants to do things
like create
a select committee on China
wants to make it bipartisan,
I think is a testament
to his prioritization
in leading this next Congress. A
Soon to be Chairman
Mike Gallagher from Wisconsin.
Good to have you.
Thank you so much for joining us
And Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas.